facebook has now researchers at Cornell
University have figured out that
Facebook can actually predict whether
you and your partner will break up
there's something called the dispersion
theory let's look at it this is the
Facebook theory of dispersion as written
by the Cornell researchers they took the
data sets of 1.3 million facebook users
listed as being in a relationship and
found that the more well connected their
mutual friends were the more likely they
were to break up now I thought this was
kind of interesting because it off hand
I would have thought if you have a lot
of mutual friends it means you have a
lot of mutual interests and a lot of
connections may be a family whatever and
that that would give you more reason to
stay together but this actually proved
the rivers I think if you have a lot of
mutual friends you're that much more
likely to wind up out at dinner one
night going wait you told him I like
this are you out of your mind I I think
much as we need separation of church and
state there is some need for separation
of family and social life and the you
know that's some overlap of course
there's some overlap but you know
sometimes I like to just go out and
spend time with people who have a
separate existence with a separate set
of interests and then when I'm done I go
home and untie my wife all right well
I'm that note let's take a couple look
at some of the other findings here so
couples with high dispersion have mutual
friends who are not well connected and
couples with low dispersion have mutual
friends who are well connected now what
I think is interesting about this and I
think you'll buy into this is that this
isn't totally a scientific survey
because the subset of people that you're
talking about here are all people that
are on Facebook which may be only a
certain type of person is on base but
not in the first place right facebook
who have chosen yes play that they're in
a relationship which is I think another
subset right I've never once said
whether or not I'm in a relationship on
facebook site we need to ask you about
yes I do I what's the situation so they
wouldn't have that data point on me I
know so I mean it's I think it's a
fascinating study because there's so
much interesting data it's a big
study right even you can look on
facebook you can see who is linked to
whom and then you can look at shared
friends with in their circle that date
is available and you can compare it and
see if you can figure something out now
I wonder you know how long did they wait
to see if these people broke up it's one
thing to say people with more mutual
friends will break up well in what
length of time all right if you wait
longer will everybody break up someone's
gonna die I think a likely outcome to UM
but there is something also to be said I
think about this hypothesis that if you
have your own life you're going to have
a stronger relationship with your
partner because you're not constantly
going to be around one another and
you're going to have a sense of
Independence in a sense of personal
identity which i think is very healthy
right and then you go home and untie
them as you said yeah after your after
their and my wife and I are inherently
anti-social I go out to do things purely
for professional reasons really and I
try to be charming and I try to look
like I'm enjoying other people's company
but I'm done perfectly manageable job
but I'm really the truth is I'm Way too
much of a narcissistic to care you know
later on today I'll be saying I was on
some show with a guy in a real very true
i don't know where yeah that's that's
coming in the information around make as
I as I go out into the world and all my
point is that despite the fact that my
wife and I have no friends we do have
high dispersion there's some point
there's always know what I'm talking
about when I start yeah you gotta have
no friends and none of those nobody
ladies mutual that's my point yes thank
God scientist here none of the people
that I don't know know the people that
my wife doesn't know brilliant right so
how then watch how I do this will the
marketers use this on facebook because
doesn't this all this is exactly why so
I'll has told me I'm not allowed to
breed with my dog that way you
definitely can't do that and other
sensor I think maybe in Kentucky they're
gonna target these individuals and say
get out make new friends Leslie that
you'll break up with your boyfriend if
you do so or that they let's go the
other way and say
the people that are more likely to break
up they're going to have the singles
websites are going to be advertising on
there I already know that yeah I plate
right there will be a targeting of the
Ashley Madison yeah yeah yeah there's
tell the people what Ashley Madison
actually Madison is a dancer the one
married person there is a very
interesting there is no service visit
keep sending me emails that say don't
waste your time have an affair don't be
sad have an affair which is just not
helping at all with anything I'm
struggling with in my life right see the
billboards all over LA it's so yeah okay
so final thought on this how much of all
this digital stuff is is really
affecting our actual relationships like
when is it going to be like are you
gonna have to Skype with someone before
you know now you go on a nap and meet
somebody but is it gonna be your enough
video skype with them first and then
you're gonna have to text image like I'm
really doing something there's something
Orwellian yeah about the idea that we
call it social networking when what
we're doing is sitting alone at home at
a computer and it's genuinely
mind-bending to think that that's
considered a social life but your
definition of a loan is that there's
nobody else in the room with you
physically and I think for a lot of
young people that's not their definition
of alone anymore and i think that
there's a whole subset of the population
who previously had a very difficult time
connecting with individuals you even
made that point earlier about atheists
for example growing up in the Bible Belt
not knowing anybody in their
neighborhood who has you know similar
views you get online and now you can
connect with people so I think that you
know they're they're positive outcomes
are negative outcomes but to say how
much of our new kind of digital world is
affecting our relationships it's
impossible to know i would say it in the
same breath it's both impossible to know
and it's completely affecting us yeah
there's no way that it couldn't I don't
know if it's positive negative or net
neutral but the way that we interact is
is completely changed because we're all
connected online hey guys the Rubin
reports brought to you by Cooper calm
they have up to seventy-five percent off
pet treats choose toys and more and if
you use code are are you get another
twenty percent that's a lot of
percentage right there I can't do that
kind of math the link is right down
below
Oh Cooper calm code RR